vous avez commencé à travailler comme
salarié comme chasseuse de tête et puis
vous avez quitté ce travail au bout de
deux mois seulement pourquoi alors parce
que je me retrouvais pas dans ce poste
là
j'ai fui je pense à deux choses c'était
un mode de vie qui me correspondait pas
passer 60 heures enfermé dans un bureau
derrière un ordi c'est parce que je
voulais
et j'ai aussi plutôt le côté sédentaire
ou c'était la durée aussi parce que moi
évidemment 60 heures par semaine ça peut
se comprendre oui le côté sédentaire de
d'arriver le matin à 8h au bureau et de
repartir avant 19h et le fait de partir
à 18h on est je sens que j'étais mal vu
en fait que j'étais regardée ça me
posait souci et ça mettait en sacrifice
d'autres choses dans ma vie que j'aime
faire en fait et j'avais plus
d'équilibre vie pro et vie perso que
aujourd'hui j'ai besoin d'avoir en fait
on va parler de ce que vous avez choisi
de faire ensuite mais vous avez déjà
fait deux ans d'alternance de stage
avant cet emploi et déjà là vous vous
étiez aperçu que vous n'adhériez pas à
la mentalité c'est quoi cette mentalité
alors moi j'ai fait cinq ans d'études
dans le commerce spécialisé dans le
sport et c'est vrai que dans certaines
expériences professionnelles je me
retrouvais pas dans le sens que je
donnais à ça
en fait j'avais l'impression que
[Musique]
certaines entreprises ou certains
managers étaient prêts à vendre à tout
prix et quand je dis à tout prix c'est
des conséquences humaines et des
conséquences aussi environnementales et
ça c'est pas quelque chose qui me plaît
la question environnementale elle est au
coeur vous de votre changement de
parcours bérangé on va commencer par
parler un petit peu peut-être de votre
vie d'avant vous avez commencé en
travaillant dans l'industrie
aéronautique qu'est-ce qui vous a
conduit déjà vous à travailler dans ce
secteur
parce que dans mes proches dans mon
entourage quand j'étais enfant j'avais
beaucoup de personnes qui travaillent
dans l'aéronautique
donc c'était vraiment par passion au
départ donc j'ai suivi cette passion
qui travaille dans cet environnement
j'ai des proches qui travaillent
là-dedans et
puis ensuite
c'était un peu par défaut et puis par
passion donc j'ai
beaucoup apprécié mes premières années
des femmes et mes années d'études
étaient super intéressantes mais ça me
nourrissait beaucoup et au final en
arrivant sur le marché du travail
ensuite ma première expérience c'était
plutôt de l'ordre de l'opérationnel donc
j'avais pas trop le temps de de cibler
enfin de visualiser les règles
commerciales les règles financière etc
de ce milieu là et
puis vous avez basculé quand même
qu'est-ce qu'il s'est passé pour que
vous vous disiez que que qu'il fallait
en partie c'est un modèle qui vous a plu
convaincu donc c'est le modèle plus le
modèle industriel en fait et puis le
volume aéronautique en général que je
trouve
trop gros et je pense pas que ce soit
très sérieux en fait
et
en fait donc je me rends compte pendant
le covid surtout
je j'ai beaucoup de temps pour moi parce
que je travaille en compagnie aérienne
donc l'activité était complètement à
l'arrêt et donc j'ai pris du temps j'ai
lu je me suis renseigné je regardais des
reportages mais tout ça plutôt axé sur
l'environnement quand même donc je me
suis je me suis pas mal instruit à ce
niveau là puis j'ai vu des choses que je
voulais certainement pas voir au départ
et puis je me suis
en tant que étudiant et puis je ne
travailleur dans ce marché pendant ce
milieu industriel assez lourd il y a
forcément des il y a toujours eu des
conseils des contestations des
concepteurs et puis quand on travaille
là-dedans en tant que jeune lancer un
peu dans ce marché et dans ce qui
s'épanouit parfois on n'a pas trop envie
d'entendre certaines choses
et au final
avec du recul il faut le covid m'a
permis de prendre cet endroit qu'il en
fait
de démissionner donc non non
et je pars de nouvelles aventures du
coup on va parler de vos projets de vos
nouvelles aventures
pas un bon David c'est
ce que
cyber cette crise vous en avez parlé
dans l'une de vos études cet été elle a
joué un rôle important dans la
transformation du rapport des Français
au travail et singulièrement des jeunes
oui elle a un incontestablement jouer un
rôle catalyseur même si on avait déjà
des signes avant-coureur avant mais il y
a une il y a un score qui est
emblématique on a posé à l'Ifop une
question même question à 30 ans
d'intervalle sur l'importance du travail
dans sa vie en 1990 Xavier 92% des
actifs qui disaient que le travail est
important aujourd'hui 86 donc il reste
important en revanche la proportion de
personnes qui considèrent qu'il est très
important c'est effondré elle est passée
de 60% en 1990 à 24% aujourd'hui donc le
travail demeure important mais il n'est
plus aussi structurant
[Musique]